you said
elon looking up there's something about
childlike wander to him
like to his personality his character
something about
i think more so than others where people
can trust them and there's uh i don't
know son of a child is an example of
somebody who's like
there's some kind
it's it's hard to put into words but
there's something about the human being
where he's trustworthy yeah he's
human
in a way that uh connects to us and the
same with uh
sadja nadella i mean some of these folks
um something about
us is drawn to them even when they're
flawed even like um so like your thesis
really holds up for steve jobs because i
think people didn't like steve jobs but
like he delivered products
that and then they fell in love every
time
i guess you could say that the ceo the
leader is also a product
and if they keep delivering a product
that people like
by being in public and saying things
that people like that's also a way to
make people happy
but from a social network perspective it
makes me
wonder how difficult it is
to explain to people why certain things
happen like how to explain machine
learning
to explain why
certain
uh
the
the woke mob effect happens or the
certain kinds of like bullying happens
which is like
it's human nature combined with
algorithm and it's very difficult to
control for how the spread of
quote-unquote misinformation happens
it's very difficult to control for that
and to you so you try to just celebrate
certain parts and you create more
problems
then you solve and anything that looks
at all like censorship can create huge
amounts of problems it's the slippery
slope and then you have to inject humans
to oversee the machine learning
algorithms and anytime you inject humans
into the system it's going to create a
huge number of problems and i feel like
it's up to the leader to communicate
that effectively to be
transparent first of all design products
that don't have those problems and
second of all when they have those
problems to be able to communicate with
them i guess that's all going to
when you run a social network company
your job is hard
yeah
i will say the one element that you
haven't named that i think you're
getting at is just bedside manner
which steve jobs
i never worked for him i never met him
in person um
had an enor like
an uncanny ability in public to have
bedside manner i mean some of the best
clips of steve jobs
from like i would say
maybe the 80s when he's on these stage
and getting questions from the audience
about life or
and he'll take this question that is
like how are you going to compete with
blah and it's super boring and i don't
even know the name of the coming and his
answer is is if you just asked like your
grandfather the meaning of life yeah
yeah and you sit there and you're just
like what like yeah and there's that
bedside manner um
and if you lack that or if that's just
not intuitive to you
uh i think that
it can be a lot harder to gain the trust
of people and then add on top of that
missteps of companies right
it's i don't know if you have any
friends from the past where like maybe
they crossed you once or like
maybe you get back together and you're
friends again but you just never really
forget that thing it's human nature not
to forget i'm russian you cost me one
we solve the problem
so my point is
it there's
humans don't forget and if there are
times in the past where they feel like
they don't trust the company or the
company hasn't had their back
that is really hard to earn back
especially if you don't have that
bedside manner um and again like i'm not
attributing this specifically to mark
because i think a lot of companies
have this issue where
one you have to be trustworthy as a
company and live by it and live by those
actions and then two i think you need to
be able to be really relatable in a way
that's very difficult if you're worth
like what these people are it's really
hard
yeah
you